Colleen claimed our video it happened
about an hour after we posted I said
Colleen Ballinger uploaded talks at
gossip during the CD Baby and claiming
us so here it is she was generous enough
to do a sharing Revenue yeah right guys
don't worry I'm disputing it she's not
gonna get you guys know me I take care
of this she's not gonna get a dollar
that's annoying it could take like two
months to resolve if she really wants to
be Petty about it but I know how to
navigate this it's just annoying and
funny I mean and crazy I hadn't heard of
anyone else being claimed and then we
got claimed about an hour after the
podcast so it does lend some some
thought to the theory that she waited
for us to go on break it's really scummy
and weird and like freakish to claim it
because it's like an apology and it's
supposed to be authentic and not
something that she's making money from
But ultimately it's very fair use
because the song was analyzed and also
the song that we made was a parody of
her original song so I think that it's
absolutely fair use